[Applaudissements]
maicon au soir emmanuel merci d'être là
avec nous on voulait pas vous déranger
c'est le prix le prix non c'est matthieu
delormeau en fait qui vous aime beaucoup
alors on a vu manuel valls il ya ça
quelques années on avait essayé d'avoir
françois hollande
voilà on a eu pas mal de gens c'est vrai
qu'on est jean luc mélenchon aussi qui
est venu ici et mathieu voilà vous êtes
son idole absolue
je sais que vous êtes en pleine campagne
si vous avez fait votre meeting dimanche
à lyon qui a vous avait démenti des
choses voilà tout ça la voilà donc
mathieu ont parlé de ça on parlait de ce
démenti est matthieu delormeau voulais
vous parler ce que vous connaissez
mathieu de l'envoi emmanuel macron alors
excusé mais je ne regarde pas l'émission
mais mon entourage me dit que vous avez
perdu les primaires face à monsieur
verdez
[Applaudissements]
et
c'est vrai à fréquenter les loosers mais
c'est vrai mais bon voilà c'était
c'était serré et un y avait soixante dix
30 bat mathieu l isi parlez-lui bonsoir
emmanuel suffrages
ce que je peux vous appeler manuel non
mais manuel c'est pas que je vous aime
énormément je voulais vous dire que
vraiment vous avez moderniser la
politique vous vous êtes vous êtes beau
vous êtes très talentueux vous êtes
notre nouveau ville et dix policiers est
ce qu'il est rationnée qui pourrait être
notre nouveau kennedy je me bats je suis
jeune et beau nom mais il parlait
l'aéroport jeu
[Applaudissements]
mais la personne voilà je me proposais
s'en vanter de ne souhaite pas on ne
vous souhaite pas la même forme
moi je me proposais sans me vanter
peut-être d'être la nouvelle jackie
voilà ils veulent des guerres ils
veulent des caveaux du tout non mais
vraiment pas du tout géré en vue de
respect pour vous j'aimerais beaucoup
qu'on se bat donc je proposais plaide
comprennent un verre dans d'un hôtel
parisien peut-être suite votre choix
commence par un bistrot vous viendriez
avec vos gardes du corps je viendrai
avec les miens c'est donc si vous avez
alors pardon messieurs de la mode oui je
suis comme la dernière canicule
moi aussi c'est les vieilles que je
dépanne en premier et je voulais vous
dire mais libéré qu'en gare
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
marc antoine est vrai qu'on est un bon
gars comme mark hurd a été fait parce
qu'il crie comme emmanuel a bien sûr et
manu